Sollte wieder funktionieren.
Hoffe ich mal, zumindest.
Oh, ich werde so abkacken, ey.
Ich werde so abkacken, genau, v.a. jetzt.
Das ist richtig krass.
Aber Lucio Kreiselgrind an der Wand, das verliert man nicht.
Hallo Mr. Dolphin.
Übrigens kann sein, dass das Stream laggt, weil ich gerade downloade.
Ich hoffe zwar nicht.
Ich hoffe zwar nicht, dass das laggt.
Aber man weiß nicht.
Hallo Papa Massive.
Alex25i
Schön, dass du da bist.
Ach, ich checke jetzt erst, warum so viele neue Leute in den Stream kommen, weil es jetzt Notifications gibt.
Ich bin eigentlich schon den ganzen Vormittag on.
Ich bin schon seit 10 Uhr oder so on.
Ich habe jetzt bloß den Stream neu gestartet.
Während das runterlädt, bin ich noch mal kurz auf dem Klo.
So, ich mache jetzt schon mal Discord an.
Ja, Kratzlasfanboy.
Also ich interpretiere das mal so, dass du jetzt gerade Master geworden bist.
Das Beat ist gerade wirklich unterirdisch schlecht.
Also Eax, ich bin im Discord drin.
Ich spiele aber gerade nicht über mein Headset.
Streamst du oft in den letzten drei Wochen?
Also davor relativ oft, aber in den letzten drei Wochen habe ich nicht mehr gestreamt.
Ich habe genauso oft gestreamt, wie ich Videos gemacht habe in den letzten drei Wochen.
Lol.
Also gar nicht.
So, ich bin gar nicht mehr Afrika, das stimmt nicht, was da steht.
So, jetzt muss ich nur noch Glück haben, dass mir mein Smurf-Account einfällt.
So, ich habe jetzt noch ein paar Videos gemacht.
Warum ist das Internet manchmal so langsam?
Das ist nicht das Internet, was langsam ist.
Ich würde mal sagen, das sind die Blizzard-Sauber, die langsam sind.
Nee, nee, das liegt auch nicht am Stream.
Geladen.
Das sind die Blizzard-Sauber.
Ja, oder wie Sebaro schreibt, dass es schlicht und ergreifend einfach nicht stimmt, was da steht.
Stimmt auch, wenn man sich die Geschwindigkeit anguckt, passt es überhaupt nicht zu dem, was da hinten steht.
So, ich habe jetzt noch ein paar Videos gemacht.
So, ja, wenigstens DuoQ.
Ja, Solo hätte, wäre er jetzt nicht im Chat gewesen oder im Stream, hätte ich gar nicht gespielt.
So, Moment.
Jetzt müssen wir nochmal ausloggen.
Und mein Smurf-Account einloggen, damit ich das richtige Passwort schreiben kann.
Jawoll. Perfekt.
Irgendwie schwackt das Game.
Also ich stelle es gleich richtig ein, sobald Overwatch gestartet ist.
Ah, jetzt startet es.
Jetzt startet es.
Das hat aber meine Einstellung nicht übernommen.
Na toll.
Moment.
Oh, komm mal, ein Blizzard.
Window-Capture.
Overwatch.
Transform, Reset.
So, jetzt muss ich nämlich erstmal einstellen.
Ganz einen Krempel hier.
Gut.
Der sieht doch schon besser aus jetzt.
Teimo sagt, man muss Fullscreen spielen, sonst geht das nicht.
Wenn das Teimo sagt, dann machen wir das auch.
Und danach kochen wir uns Teimo Meatballs.
Game Capture müssen wir jetzt machen.
Game Capture Overwatch.
So, jetzt muss ich erstmal gucken, ob man was sieht.
Sieht man überhaupt was jetzt?
Ja, wunderbar, Fullscreen funktioniert.
PMA.
Nee, ich glaube bei mir wird heute nicht PMA.
Stimmen denn die Settings überhaupt, die ich hier habe?
60?
144, ich wollte gerade sagen, da stimmt doch was nicht.
Ehe ja, ich bin übrigens im Discord.
So, Graphics, Quality.
Oh nee, das sind ja überhaupt... Scheiße, da sind nicht mal meine Settings drinne hier.
Okay, ich muss eh neu starten.
Oh mein, Render Scale, the fuck?
Texture Quality.
High, Filtering, Low, Low.
Ich lasse das jetzt einfach mal so stehen.
Shadows, Shadows machen wir mal off.
Model, Detail.
Ich weiß meine Settings vom besten Weg.
Ich mach mal alles low. Scheiß drauf.
Scheiß drauf.
Controls.
Ja gut, das stimmt noch.
Sensitiv für die Sieben, das hat sich wohl gemerkt, okay.
Okay, ich start noch mal neu.
Genku.
Okay.
Übrigens danke für die ganzen Follows heute wieder.
Ach ja, und ich hab in Overwatch übrigens keinen Ingame Sound, also keine Musik an.
Moment, warum hab ich Musik?
Hä, das stimmt hinten und vorne nicht.
Ja, Push to Talk.
Test, Test.
Push to Talk geht halt mal einfach nicht.
Das probieren wir gleich aus.
Ich spiel 800 DPI, sieben Ingame.
Das ist für schnelle Klassen sowas wie Lucio ganz gut.
Wenn man jetzt der Unterklasse mit Creepro ist, dann wahrscheinlich nicht.
Kannst du kurz deine Meinung zu Java FX abgeben?
Ich weiß mit Ach und Krach was es ist.
Also, nee, kann ich dir nicht viel zu sagen.
Ja, haben wir uns überhaupt geendet?
Mit den Smurf Accounts?
Ich hab hier nämlich nicht viele. Nee, ich hab dich hier gar nicht drauf, gell?
Discord, okay.
Ah ja, nee, nee, ich zeug nicht mit meinem Main, hab ich jetzt keinen Bock.
Wir müssen eh mit beiden noch Placements machen, du mit Dynamo und ich mit dem hier dann.
Leute adden, add a friend.
So, müsste es einen Request haben.
Was ist dein High auf Main? 4000 oder so?
In Season 2?
Irgendwie sowas, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Also es war quasi schon Top 500 in Season 2 damals, zumindest gerade so, noch bevor es rausgekommen ist.
Irgendwie hab ich es mir in Season 3 anders überlegt, da hatte ich ja gar keinen Bock mehr.
So, also wenn du willst, kannst du in Overwatch Channel kommen auf dem Discord.
Spielst du LoL? Nee.
So, ich muss mir das mal eher entweiten hier in Game Social.
Yes, servus.
Moin. Wir müssen jetzt mal kurz Lautstärketest machen.
Ob das so passt?
Wir sind noch beim letzten Mal hier, mega laut.
Ich glaube, das passt.
Leute, ihr müsst während dem Game einfach mal sagen, wie laut Stärke es ist.
Ich glaube es...
Das müsste ich auf 40% runterstellen.
Ja, sag gleich mal, wenn in Game Sound ist, wie das passt und was wir noch einstellen müssen.
Okay, ich hab's ewig nicht mehr gespielt.
Sag mal, hast du bei Display Settings irgendwas Besonderes?
Also anstatt alles auf Low hast du da irgendwelche speziellen Sachen?
Nee, gar nichts. Aber ich hab auch das NDR-Lasing nicht drin.
Das ist Standard bei mir hier, oder?
Ja, du hast doch hier FXAA drin.
Ach so, du hast auf off?
Oh nee, ganz off halte ich nicht aus.
Echt?
Nee, ganz off geht nicht.
Das ist wie noch die Model Details oben, damit es nicht ganz so hoch ist.
Stimmt, stimmt. Ja, das könnte ich noch. Model Details war ich noch hoch.
Leute, schreibt mal, wie der Sound von Erx ist und wie, also meine Lautstärke, Erx-Lautstärke und so, ob das passt.
Ansonsten kann ich schon ein bisschen dran rumdrehen.
Du hast recht, mach Model Details, Details, Details, mach ich hoch.
Wo ist es denn überhaupt hier?
Ultra, mach mal.
Some Requires New Start, nein, okay, dann mach ich's nicht.
Ich such mal ein Game, du musst ja auch noch Placements machen.
Naja, mach schon.
Ach Gott, das wird grausam.
Das wird grausam.
Ja, mir kommt das gerade gelegen, dann kann ich mal wieder mein Genji ausparken.
Ja, mach das, mach, oh Gott.
Bestimmt bei drei Season nicht dargefasst.
Reduce Buffering, oh ja, stimmt, das müssen wir machen, das ist jetzt ja neu.
Wo steht denn das überhaupt hier?
Video.
Wo ist denn das?
Wo steht denn Reduce Buffering?
Das ist drei Zeilen unter Aspect Ratio.
Bei Graphics Quality oder bei, ach nee.
Ganz oben.
Reduce Buffering, on.
War das nicht verbackt und hat sich immer wieder gesettet?
Hast du irgendwas gelesen?
Du, keine Ahnung.
Okay, wir haben Ping von Null.
Ich glaub mal, die Anzeige stimmt nicht so ganz.
Oh Gott, wir haben Game jetzt.
Eine gescheite Map zum Start.
Easy.
Also ich hab ja erwartet, wir starten mit 2CP und so.
Ich hab auch gedacht, wir starten mit 2CP.
Komm, ich spiel mal was, was ich kann.
Ich spiel mal was, was ich kann.
Okay, es kommt mir noch bekannt vor.
Ich hab, weißt du, kennst du das, wenn du ein Spiel eine Weile nicht mehr gespielt hast,
und dann wieder reinkommst, kommt dir das so halbbekannt,
als weißt du, du hast massig Zeit drin verbracht.
Aber es ist trotzdem ungewohnt.
Na ja.
Es kommt dir zwar bekannt vor und so manche Sachen,
so hier irgendwie Walljumpen machst du nur automatisch.
Oh Gott, das ist ja nichts eingestellt.
Du hast 40 Sekunden Zeit.
Ist Lucio kleiner geworden oder war die Map schon immer so groß?
Ach, der erste Liefer.
Der Match wird eh abgebrochen.
Du kommst ja nicht mehr zum Einsteigen oder so.
Leute, ihr habt es gerade gehört, Soundabstimmung war okay zwischen uns und Ingame und alles.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass Lucio gereworked wurde?
Ja, das kenn ich noch.
Nach dem Motto mehr Damage und kleinere Aura-Radius und sowas, das kenn ich noch.
Vielleicht wartest du gerade schon Season 4?
Willst du den Match suchen?
Ich wollte warten, bis du Einstellungen gemacht hast.
Nee, nee, kann ich schon machen.
Wann war Lucio reworked?
Season 4 oder Ende Season 3 oder so?
Schon eine Weile her.
Da habe ich noch kurz gespielt, das weiß ich noch.
Go, go.
Wie viele Stunden hast du in dem Game?
Schwer zu schätzen.
1000? Keine Ahnung.
Also wir haben ja wirklich verdammt viel gespielt, vor allem auch schon in der Beta und sowas.
Aber ich habe halt jetzt seit drei Seasons nicht mehr gespielt.
Also Leute, ich werde jetzt sacken, das ist euch schon klar.
Schaust du Contenders? Ja.
Sofern das von der Zeit her passt, wenn es nicht gerade mitten in der Nacht ist.
Gestern Nacht habe ich ein bisschen geguckt, bin schon mal eingepennt nach Misfits.
Ist gestern mal aufgefallen bei der WM, die haben ja jetzt irgendwie so ein Aim-Smoving drin oder sowas, eine Option dafür.
Was soll denn da gesmoost werden? Das muss ich rausschmeißen.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich will das was, ich soll nichts gesmoost werden.
Das ist meistens scheiße, wenn was gesmoost wird.
Jawoll, 2CP, fängt gut an.
Moment, warum kriegen wir Master und Crapmaster Leute drin? Was ist das? Game!
Ich glaube, das kommt gleich noch an.
Bist du im Ingame-Voice oder nicht?
Nee, gerade nicht.
Hat sich was am Ranking-System geändert? Nee, nicht wirklich.
Angeblich ist es jetzt viel fairer.
Ich kann nicht sagen, Dark Duty, also Maus habe ich eine Zoe EC2A, Maus-Pad ein Rocket-Hero, hattest du das nicht auch?
Das Rocket-Maus-Pad oder was hattest du für ein Maus-Pad?
Du hattest so ein mega fettes, ne?
Ja, das Steelseries QCK XXL oder so was.
Ach stimmt, das hatte ich mir auch gekauft, das hat so krass gestunken, das hängt immer noch im Hof.
Das konnte ich nicht bei mir ins Arbeitszimmer stellen, das geht nicht.
Du hast das nie wieder reingehangen.
Nee, das hängt immer noch im Hof, das stinkt immer noch.
Okay, Moment, ich muss jetzt erstmal halbwegs durchspringen.
Also wir kommen jetzt erstmal schön in den Master Grandmaster-Game rein, das finde ich schon mal super.
Ich dachte wir können jetzt erstmal ein bisschen easy machen hier.
Ich halte, ich halte, oh fuck.
Ich hab den aufgeweckt, den Typ.
Wir könnten jetzt eigentlich, wobei, können wir die überpushen?
Fuck, fuck, fuck.
Okay, jetzt wurde ich geschleibt.
Das fängt gut an, das fängt richtig gut an.
Mein Crosshair ist übrigens voll fail, ne?
Ich muss den Typ mal ausschalten.
Oh, Winston, was geht mit dir ab? Alter!
Was macht unser Winston allein da vorne, kannst du mir das mal erklären?
Das fängt voll gut an.
Oh nee, ich wurde gekillt mit Ulti.
Scheiße.
Move dich, move dich, move dich, move dich.
Ich versuch's mal, aber das ist gut, solange die auf mir sind, sind sie nicht auf den Punkt.
Ey, ey, ey.
Komm, ich komm mal zurück.
Voll die Rakete rein.
Ich glaub die Fahrer kommt rechts, nee die ist oben in der Mitte.
Der Winston ist richtig im Yolo-Modus.
Tracer und Winston sind auf der rechten Hand.
Da wird geschlitzt.
Haben die noch ne Widow? Nee, die haben geswitcht.
Die haben rausgeswitcht, ja.
Winston, Winston, Winston, nicht verrecken.
Oh man, wir sind mega verteilt.
Was, mit her? An Spot. Spot, ja.
Was ist das für ne Mischung aus Spielern?
Können die uns bitte mal nicht in den Master hören, Mastergames schlafen am Anfang.
Jetzt würd sich der Grandmaster auch gedacht haben. Ja, den geh ich auch mal von aus.
Tracer rechts.
Oh, geschlitzt. Gaming mit Schlips, die Widow gibt's nicht mehr.
Contestant, Contestant, Contestant.
2 CP.
Der Genji ist fast tot.
Oh fuck.
Da muss man sterben, Jungs, da muss man sterben.
Ich hab gleich Ulti, wenn sie wieder rankommen.
Ich glaub doch auch nix, ne? Nee, da stirbt nix, gar nix. Jetzt hab ich wieder Ulti. Toll.
2 CP.
Rest gibt's nicht.
Jetzt hab ich eigentlich auf dem Account hauptsächlich gespielt.
Naja, gut, diese Season muss ich nicht gucken.
Ana. Ana und Lucio.
Moment, lohnt es sich Diablo 3 jetzt noch zu holen? Warum fragst du das nicht? Keine Ahnung.
Ja, sie baroziert um Flex, die Taste die gibt's auf der Rückseite.
Was hat unser Team wieder für Probleme?
Contestant mit all den Freunden, ich komm auch alleine.
Sind das die Niederländer? Das sind keine Franzosen oder so, sonst hätt ich jetzt flamen können.
Ich muss mir das von Teimo abgucken, PMA.
Ich hab in Hannenfalken gehört oder bin ich blöd?
Eigentlich würd ich lieber rechts laufen anstatt links.
Aber unsere Leute waren links.
Bauleute, Bauleute.
Wow, ich war's nett, ich war's nett.
Moment, ich bin wieder.
Fuck, ich bin noch.
Okay, ich bring die Leute mit.
Ja, wie geht denn das bitte?
Das ist doch nicht möglich.
Winston ist rechts.
Winston, mach nen Schild, mach nen Schild.
Ich bin gleich wieder da, der Winston geht ab.
Oh nee, wir haben's, wir haben's falsch.
Ich muss mich an die kleineren Kreise von Lucio gewöhnen, da ist ja kaum noch Range.
Nee, nee, ich mach jetzt keine Ulti.
Ich musste jetzt, hier blieb nichts anderes übrig, der Genji ging ganz rein gegangen.
Fuck.
How far is your Dragonblade WTF, was geht mit dem Typ ab? Der Genji hat den grad rausgehauen.
Geil, haben wir einen Bick und dann fertig uns der links, der Winston, Schild.
Moment, wo ist denn der Winston?
Ach, der Winston ist tot.
Winston ist rein, go go.
Voll in die Kresse.
Ja, das mit der Tastatur ist ein bisschen nervig, ich hab heut keinen Headset auf, ich hab Mikrofon auf dem Schreibtisch stehen.
Wenn's gar so nervig ist, kann ich das umstellen.
Ich kann aber das Mikrofon einfach ein bisschen hochklappen, dann ist es vielleicht nicht ganz so schlimm.
Vielleicht ist es jetzt besser.
Der Winston ist in Jolo-Modus, wir müssen vor.
Ich hab gleich wieder Ulti, gleich wieder Ulti.
Soldier ist oben rechts.
Soldier verpisst dich.
Ich muss die Ana holen.
Was? Warum? Warum sind alle tot?
Oh nee, jetzt kriegen wir auf den Sack.
Alles blöd.
Okay, Healing Dunn ist wenigstens noch gut dabei.
Mensch, Komfort, oh fuck, zu spät.
Ich seh die ganze Zeit, wie die Ana Heelfeile an mir vorbeischießt.
Die hat sich so mit Heilen so großartig.
Leute, warum geht ihr denn schon rein? Uns fehlen noch Leute.
Wir haben erst den Winston hinter uns.
Das war so knickend gerade.
Lass mal gucken, Jungs.
Wir haben noch einen guten Push, ich hab gleich Ulti, neun Prozent.
Oh, der Winston geht rein, wir müssen.
Der Soldier ist wieder oben links.
Hier ist die Shrimp.
Anstrengend.
So, vielleicht jetzt mal ein bisschen Easy Mode Game nächste Runde, bitte.
Weißt du schon ungefähr, wo du landen wirst?
Das ist mein erstes Spiel seit drei Seasons, das erste Placement Match.
Siehst du uns raus?
Ich muss jetzt erst mal ein abrubbeln auf meine Stats.
So, jetzt geht's.
Also das kann man doch nicht abschätzen, gleich nächste.
Woran hat's gelegen?
Ich würde mal sagen, der hauptsächliche Sache war mangelnde Koordination zusammen, so wie das bei den meisten Games ist.
Also wenn du schon siehst, dass quasi der Winston alleine vorne ist und keiner mitzieht und sowas in der Richtung, das ist immer so gewollt und nicht gekonnt.
Oder er ist, woran willst du sagen, hat's gelegen?
Da wird nur eine D.Va gebraucht.
D.Va war auch gut gewesen, aber ich weiß nicht koordinationstechnisch war auch jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Ja, das Ding ist halt, die hatten Graf immer, die hatten ja gar nichts dagegen, Impulsbomb und Nanoweise.
Ja, eine D.Va wäre richtig gut gewesen.
Hättest du im Zweifelsfall mit Glück auch ein bisschen Glingsgesager fressen können, wenn's gut gelaufen wäre.
Ja.
Du kannst fragen, was ich für eine Maus habe. Ich hab eine Zowie Z2A.
Bin ich mal gespannt, was jetzt kommt.
Jetzt kommt wahrscheinlich Mooncolony. Ja, genau. Das ist die schlimmste Map.
Das ist echt die schlimmste Map.
Aber es fängt schon gut an. Erstes Match krieg ich gleich gelust.
Na, ihr fand so rein balance-technisch war das schon in Ordnung.
Das ging. Also wir hätten das auch gewinnen können.
Aber mir wäre es trotzdem ganz lieb, wenn die das Ernst mein mit Rank verfällt.
Also sprich, wenn du drei Seasons nicht gespielt hast, dann wirst du halt auch erstmal wieder Gold oder so in den Placements eingestuft.
Vielleicht gehen wir da auf den Ost, Platin, Diamond, so werden wir rumlanden.
Nee, ich meinte jetzt auch hier in den Placements, die sollten uns halt keine Master Grandmaster hinschmeißen.
Weil ich mein, das ist man halt einfach nach drei, drei, vier Monaten gespielt immer. Egal was man vorher war.
Ja, stimmt schon.
Sollten sie Diamond, Gold, Platin, Diamond-Matches machen und wenn man die halt dann die ganze Zeit alles abrockt, dann können sie einen ja auch hochstufen.
Ich finde, selbst wenn du schon einen Monat nicht zockst, dann...
Ja, du bist total aus der Übung.
Und was richtig auffällig ist, wie koordiniert die Leute jetzt mittlerweile spielen im Ranked, also Anführungsstrichen koordiniert, dass die in Anubis beispielsweise alle oben stehen und sowas.
Das hat es ja früher nicht gegeben. Da ist ja jeder woanders rumgerannt.
Oh, wir haben ein Match. Mal gucken, was jetzt kommt.
Dorado!
Ui.
Moment, kann das sein? Warum haben wir vier Grandmaster?
Game! Game, bitte! Blitz!
Guck mal ins Gegnerteam so.
Game, Blitz. Komm her. Aber wir haben Genji.
Ich habe mir bei der Vade das Circle-Crosser vom Timur abkopiert. Das ist richtig geil.
Aber das wollte ich mir auch noch einstellen. Letztens, der hat so einen...
Imigur, oder wie diese Seite heißt, von seinen Settings. Wollte ich auch kopieren, wenn ich wieder anfange.
Also mit Crosshair-Settings, Grafik-Settings und alles. Nicht, weil man dann wirklich so spielt wie Timur, oder?
Manche Leute, also ich habe jetzt die Maus, die Timur hatte ich auch nicht.
Aber die Settings werden schon was bringen.
Man sollte echt mal so eine Show machen, irgendwie so Germany's Next Timu, auch wenn es kein deutscher ist. Egal.
Weil wir haben ja auch ein paar deutsche Pros.
Da kommen wahrscheinlich Fire and Mercy oder sowas. Auf jeden Fall Mercy ist dabei.
Genji, Pharah, Zen.
Moment, oh! Unser Reinhardt, unser Reinhardt!
Hat das geschafft? Ja.
Ich glaube, die Pharah fliegt gerade oben lang irgendwo.
Der Reinhardt kriegt massiv auf die Fresse. Jetzt hat es dauernd.
Ich bleibe mal am Paylord dran.
War alles verloren? Ich bin auch am Paylord dran.
Das checkt bloß gerade keiner.
Jetzt aber, jetzt bin ich down.
Komm nach oben.
Schon krass, der gegnerische Vincent jump solo rein, aber kein Fokus.
Sag mal, was geht denn hier eigentlich gerade?
Kannst du speedboosten? Ja.
Was ist die Mercy?
Den Tracer ist über uns.
Ich bin am Paylord vorne, was mir nicht allzu viel bringt.
Alter, die schrecken uns aber.
Wir haben auch nichts wirklich Großartiges. Na doch, wir haben halt einen Soldier-Anti.
Und wenn die D.Va ein bisschen was frisst, sollte das gehen.
Okay, wir engageen jetzt zusammen mit Ulti.
Aber wenn sie etwas frisst, dann dürfte da schon was gehen, aber die Mercy ist halt nicht mehr.
Fuck.
Ich wusste auch, wir haben übeles Damage gekriegt.
Aber das sollten wir haben.
Fuck, was hoch?
Wo ist der Genji?
Was geht denn hier gerade ab?
Geht geschlitzt.
Ich versuche wieder vom Spawn hinzukommen. Ah, unsere Mercy hat gewetzt, okay.
Scheiße.
Ich komme mal zu dir hoch.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck. Ich komme wieder runter. Oh nee.
Da guckt er das an. Alter.
Ich habe gleich Ulti wieder.
Kriegen wir denn Rats? Ah, die Mercy hat keinen.
Kommt so nichts. Also ich habe permanent... Wir müssen ran.
Oh, der Genji, der Genji, da geht noch was ran. Leute, ran, ran, ran.
Alter, ist ja gut.
Das kannst du sowas von knicken, also. Eigentlich gar nichts.
Genji benutzt permanent seine Ulti um mich zu killen, Vince benutzt seine Ulti, Tracer haut die ganze Zeit die Pulsbombe auf mich.
Voll geplatzt, ey.
Ich würde jetzt ganz gerne für die Plays mal so ein paar Easy Mode Games kriegen.
Sowas wie es am Anfang war, weißt du, alle unranked, das ist gut.
Das sieht auch ganz brauchbar aus.
Du kannst dir den vorstellen, ich komme aus dem Spawn raus, kommt direkt Vince entgegen mit seiner Primal Rage.
Da komme ich das nächste Mal aus dem Spawn raus, Pulsbombe auf mir. Und beim nächsten Mal Genji Blade.
Richtig ätzend.
Wirst du dieses Season wieder aktiv spielen oder ist heute Ausnahme? Ich weiß noch nicht.
Aktuell ist gerade mal eher abkacken angesagt.
Wo ist jetzt eigentlich der Meta-Ausgang? Wo geht man jetzt hier raus zur Zeit?
Oben.
Junkrat.
Ich würde auch nicht wundern, wenn die Symmetra haben oder sowas.
Habe ich in letzter Zeit in Streams relativ oft gesehen, ich weiß alle warum.
Ja, ich heile, ich heile durch die Leute.
Ich push weiter.
Oh, ich werde gesandwicht am Kart.
Wo ist denn der Junkrat? Ich push mal weiter.
Ich glaube vorne links ist noch was.
Ich bleibe am Kart.
Ich bleibe auf dem Kart stehen. Irgendeiner muss was machen. Sind ja schon alle weg.
Der kommt von hinten. Über das Dach.
Halb, halb.
Alter, der Junkrat geht mir mal so auf den Sack.
Ich schiebe weiter, ich schiebe weiter. Soldier noch hinter dem Payload.
Der kommt vor. Irgendwo ist der Tracer noch am Start. Hinter uns, ganz hinter uns.
Ich mache die Mercy, die Mercy hat gerade gerätzt.
Die D.Va lebt wieder.
Hier noch am Kart.
Steckt.
In your face.
Das ist ja viel zu anstrengend.
Ich dachte, wir kommen es nach drei, vier Monaten wieder erst mal easy, aber nee.
Genji, komm her.
Die D.Va war vielleicht wasted. Die D.Va war wasted.
Die D.Va ist fast tot, die D.Va.
Wo ist der Soldier?
Jetzt brauchen sie circa.
Ich bin hinterm Payload in Deckung.
Genji hüpft noch rum.
Genji auf mir, fuck, konnte ich nichts machen.
Ich habe den Mei auf mir.
Mann, das müssen wir noch durchkriegen.
Fuck, ich warte, ich warte hier auf den.
Vielleicht wieder da.
Schrecken, alles Schrecken.
Wir sind sogar noch schneller als die Gegner.
Solche Runden habe ich nicht mal auf meinem Mei.
Das ist wirklich anstrengend.
Manara, was meine Mains in Overwatch sind, Lucio, Ana, das mit weitem Abstand.
Ganzen Supports eigentlich, bis auf Mercy, dann noch ein bisschen Off-Tanks, so was wie D.Va, Winston, so was.
Also eigentlich alle Klasse, wo man kein Skill braucht.
Kannst du das so in der Nacht sagen?
Bei DPS ist es einfach so, auch wenn alle immer schreiben, du musst als DPS carryen.
Und die anderen sind dafür da, dass unter anderem mit dem DPS ermöglicht wird zu carryen.
Das ist der Job von BPS.
Ziemlich sicher, die kommen wieder mit den gleichen Sachen, oder?
Ja, das hat ja auch gut geklappt.
Oder Torb, pass auf, Torb kommt jetzt.
Ah, glaube ich bei den Gegnern nicht.
Oh Leute, haut ab.
Ich halte, ich halte, ich halte, passt.
Die kommen.
Was machen? Wir müssen bald mal contesten, unser Genji geht runter.
Ich hole dich, ich hole dich, ich hole dich.
Leute, wo hüpft ihr denn alle rum? Wir sind mega verteilt.
Der Genji, der Genji tot.
Ich, ich conteste.
Ich hab gleich Ulti.
Zehn Prozent.
Der Gegner Lucio hat ja immer viel.
Ich bin am payload ziemlich alleine.
Jetzt pass.
Gengu.
Okay, das Ausweichen mit Lucio funktioniert noch.
Das ist mein Swerve-Account, ja.
Aber das ist Absicht, dass wir jetzt mit dem Swerve-Account spielen.
Wie gesagt, Chops hat drei Seasons dann mal gespielt.
So, easy jetzt, komm.
Wir haben die, naja, ein bisschen spät gestoppt, wenn es darum geht, um die am Chalkpoint zu halten.
Aber es geht schon, ein Vibe und wir sind durch.
Ah, da ist der Gegner.
Okay, ich nehme den Meta-Ausgang.
Tierkomplex, der ist hinten auf der Tastatur.
Symmetra, hab ich das richtig gesehen, ja.
Symmetra, ich pushe übrigens, weil sonst keiner pusht.
Nice, nice, nice, erster Down.
Nicht verrecken, Jungs, nicht verrecken.
Ich pushe, ich pushe, ich bin übrigens gleich durch.
Mei steht nebenan.
Wir sind gleich durch, easy.
Was war denn das für eine Defense gerade?
Es war, es war nichts auf dem Weg, ne?
Ich hab mehr oder weniger die ganze Zeit auf dem Payload gestanden.
Du weißt doch, umso weniger Eats es ist, umso mehr kann man Eats sagen am Ende.
Ist das anstrengend.
Yeah, ich wort mich jetzt erst.
Vom Payload gestanden.
Ah, fünf Minuten, er wurde gekreiselt.
Boah ey, was für ein Game, ohne Scheiß.
Viel zu anstrengend.
Ist der Mercy-Change live fragt einer?
Hast du eine Ahnung was für Mercy-Change ist?
Nee, noch nicht.
Was gibt's denn für Mercy?
Wir wollen ja irgendwie so das Ultimate ändern, damit du damit fliegen kannst, schneller ballerts.
Was, schneller ballern?
Moment, wird Mercy mit Ultimate jetzt zum DPS oder wie?
Keine Ahnung, frag mich nicht.
Auf jeden Fall wird eh scheinbar zum Res.
Weil in 30 Sekunden kannst du einen ressen.
Ich queue mal.
Also das heißt, der Res wird eine normale Fähigkeit, aber nur noch Single Target.
Und dafür kriegt Mercy als Ultimate quasi kurz mal DPS-Status.
Also ich will nicht sagen, das stimmt nicht, was du erzählst, weil das wird wahrscheinlich wirklich so sein.
Aber das klingt mir irgendwie nicht mehr nach Mercy, sondern...
Aber gut, die Balance-Sachen sind eh teilweise fragwürdig.
Ich sag nur Junkrat, schmeißt zwei Minen rein und alles schlägt durch die Gegend.
Jeff will Mercy skilllastiger machen, okay.
Das ist ja nicht schlecht.
Ich glaube aber es ist eine schmale Balance zwischen quasi skilllastiger machen und es muss halt auch Rewarding sein.
Weißt du wie ich mein?
Also es bringt nichts, wenn du eine Klasse machst, die halt ultra skilllastig ist.
Aber halt selbst wenn du die auf Meganiveau spielst, die quasi so gut ist wie was anderes, was du mit einer Hand spielen kannst.
Ist halt die Frage, wie sie das machen. Das ist ein schmaler Grad, das hinzukriegen.
Soll D.Va noch mal generft werden? Hast du da irgendwas von gehört?
Ja, die Defense-Maschrix wird abgeändert und scheinbar kann sie dann so Paketen ballern und so ein Kram.
Aha, okay.
Ich muss mir das mal wieder durchlesen.
Das muss man natürlich dann machen, nachdem ein Junkrat so stark bufft.
Dann muss man die Defense-Maschrix werfen.
Ja stimmt schon. Ach man, kriegst du im Film mal Easy Game, Easy Life.
Ich bleib auf Lucio, weil ich würde jetzt ja was anderes spielen.
Wenn es halt Games werden, wo wir es uns erlauben können, was anderes zu spielen.
Und nicht irgendwie drei GM Games nach drei, vier, fünf, ne, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf GMs einfach mal drinne.
Man, Blizzard Blitz, Jeff Blitz. Einfach mal ein paar Easy Runden.
Lucio Voice, please. Machen wir. Ach, du bist auch in Voice, ne?
Hello, hello.
Hello.
One Hand Project.
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt Sachen erzählen, kein Mist, aber bei dem Namen, gibt es da Wots von?
Stelle ich mir interessant vor, so One Hand DPS Main.
Das würde ich mir gerne mal angucken.
Aber Respekt.
Das Schild ist fast schon wieder down ey.
Schrecken, Schrecken. Achtung, Achtung, komm mal zurück.
Achtung, Achtung, der Chunkrat, äh nicht der Chunkrat, ich meine der Router.
Ich gucke gerade auf mein Schild von 2800, einer Sekunde so.
Der ist schon krank.
Ja, aber das war jetzt auch nichts mit, was hab ich denn hier getroffen gerade?
Ich hab schon mal keine, bitte, aber einen Hanzo. Das heißt, One Shot Potential ist da.
Ich bin noch weit von der Ulti weg.
Ich versuch zu heilen, hinter uns, hinter uns, ein Genji.
So, 90 Prozent.
Schöner Solo Ruck.
Was war das?
Der Router kann aber viel.
Okay Leute, ihr müsst rankommen, ihr müsst rankommen, ihr kommt ran.
Down.
Ja, die Turns waren richtig gut, sonst wären wir jetzt sowas von gewiped.
Nicht nur gewiped, wir wären geraped.
Meine Lucio Ult war auch gerade sehr fragwürdig.
Rechts oben Hanzo.
Hanzo immer noch rechts, rechte Seite oben.
Router rechts.
Hier hab ich den Lucio da jetzt.
Man warst es nicht.
Ich hab Ulti, Hanzo ist oben links.
Da konnte ich leider nicht mehr heilen, als an dir dran stehen.
Oh nee, jetzt haben wir es gleichzeitig gedrückt. Perfekt. Scheiße.
Wir haben jetzt genau gleichzeitig unsere Support-Uls gedrückt.
Wie die letzten K-Knops.
Hanzo rechts, rechte Seite.
Ich versuch euch irgendwie alle zu heilen.
Fuck. Ich dachte ihr kommt jetzt rechts um die Ecke.
Wir sollten nicht ganz so sehr raus extenden.
Hanzo rechts, rechte Seite.
Oh nee, jetzt haben wir auch noch Zeit.
Ja, ich bin noch in der Promo, drittes Game.
Wie ich einfach mal ewig nett gespielt habe, wenn ich dir meine History angucke.
Vor allem auf dem Account, das ist grausam.
Season 3 war das, ewig Mitte Season 3.
Machst du heute alle 10 Matches? Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Aber das ist gut, dass wir das aufs Wurf machen, dann juckt es mich nicht ganz so sehr.
Eigentlich ist es bescheuert, eigentlich könnte es mich auf allen Accounts nicht jucken.
Aber trotzdem, auf dem Main Account juckt es mich irgendwie mehr, wenn ich verrecke, bzw. wenn man Games verliert.
Ja, ich schaum gleich mal rein.
Tracer ist Sombra unten drinnen.
Ist da jemand? Hallo?
Du bist hier auf dem Punkt.
Gehackt.
Zarya noch auf dem Punkt. Moment, WTF?
Ich hab's nicht gecheckt, das Ding war Sombra gehackt.
Stop dying, beste Strats. Jetzt kommen die Pro Strats.
Ich spiele gleich wieder da.
Go, go, go, go, I've got my Mecha.
Das ist irgendwie nichts gestorben gerade.
Das sind schon ein paar Dinger gestorben hier. Hansu, Sombra war da unten.
Aber danach kann nichts werden.
Das passt schon, die haben jetzt auch einiges raus. Ich schulme uns den Zen ab.
Nicht sterben, wir haben keinen Heal vorne gerade.
Was? Was? Was?
Was bin ich jetzt? Ich war doch schon längst durch.
Ich bin schon längst durch.
Du hattest 2-3 Töne auf Mecha.
Unten unten unten, eine Sombra.
Müssen wir wieder warten.
Ich hab gleich Ulti.
Ist das Yolo?
Oh nein.
Ich muss euch noch heilen, Kleiner. Ich bin aber noch nicht da.
Siehst du das Yolo?
Ich hab wieder Ulti.
Wo ist denn die Sombra hin?
Die lassen sich aber auch nicht richtig heilen.
Was ist das hier?
Also es ist total unkoordiniert gerade. Auf jeder Seite geht ein bisschen was.
Das läuft nicht.
Sind jetzt eigentlich alle da?
Ich hole den Junker jetzt ab.
Was gibt das denn, wenn es fertig ist?
Ich hab seit 50 Minuten irgendwie meine Soundflasche und wir kommen zu keinem Push.
Wir können den Soldier auch einfach rechts klicken.
Ihr habt übrigens keinen Support, wir sind beinahe tot.
Wir kommen so schnell wie es geht wieder mit Speed.
Ich geh da ab.
Wir haben zwei Minuten darum gehampelt ohne zu pushen.
Ich hatte die Soundflasche so schnell wieder.
Da hat er uns aber auseinander genommen.
Also er hat links geklickt.
Ich muss mich selbst warten.
Also ich try halt zwar auch, aber mich stößt gerade nicht.
Was geiles sind die ganzen Flame Typen wieder.
So bis gleich.
Leute als ich heute noch Overwatch spiele hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Und wisst ihr was das Schlimmste ist?
Macht mal Abtime.
Aber das bringt nichts, weil ich hab einen Stream zwischendrin neu gestartet.
Ich bin seit fast 8 Stunden online.
Gut Box.
Ein Gengu im Olds, weil ich auch so oft Genji spiele.
Blackfeuer, was spielst du denn sonst?
Ich hab eigentlich gerade kein Hauptzucht-Game.
Ich hab die letzten Monate relativ viel Black Desert online gespielt.
Aber das hat jetzt auch nachgelassen ein bisschen wieder.
Wobei, was heißt ein bisschen nachgelassen?
Ich spiel eigentlich kaum noch.
Ich mach Daily Rewards.
Und ansonsten halt ab und zu mal ein bisschen die älteren Battlefields noch.
Aber seit ich mit Overwatch aufgehört hab, hatte ich kein so richtiges Sucht-Game mehr.
Ich kann so mal sagen, das lag gar nicht mal an Overwatch selbst.
Ich finde, Overwatch ist an sich im Kern immer noch ein ultra geiles Game und ist eines der besten Sachen, die Blizzard seit 10 Jahren oder so rausgebracht hat.
Aber das Rank-System tiltet mich immer so krass.
Das ist nicht mehr normal.
Das ist nicht normal.
Und das wollte ich mir immer geben, zumal ich das Rank-System auch für ziemlich unfair halte.
Und im letzten Developer-Update haben sie also Sachen besprochen wie Reporting-System und sowas in der Richtung.
Also ich mein, klar, es ist wichtig, dass das Reporting-System ordentlich funktioniert.
Aber ich finde, man könnte schon viel Toxic-Kram aus ranked generell rausnehmen,
wenn man zum Beispiel sowas einführen würde, wie die Leute könnten sich für Rollen anmelden beim Queuen.
Also ich würde jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, hey, play, competitive.
Und ich sag, ich würde gerne Support spielen.
Und andere Leute queuen sich mit, ja, ich würde gerne DPS spielen.
Und andere Leute queuen sich mit, ich würde gerne Tank spielen und was auch immer.
Man könnte sogar sagen, dass man zwei Sachen auswählt, also quasi so eine Main-Kategorie und eine Backup-Kategorie.
Dann würde ich dann quasi sowas ankreuzen, wie ich würde gerne hauptsächlich Support spielen.
Allerdings, off Tank geht auch oder sowas in der Richtung.
Oder man könnte es sogar Helden-basiert machen, dass man einfach die Helden auswählt, mit denen man sich gut fühlt und auf die man heute Bock hat.
Und dann würde das Matchmaking halt gucken, dass sofern es irgendwie möglich ist, so Leute zusammenkommen.
Das wäre schon mal gut, das würde dafür sorgen, dass die Teamkoms was taugen.
Dann fände ich es auch super, wenn One-Trick-Sachen an sich nicht mehr so belohnt werden würden.
Mercy Main, by the way.
Und vor allem, wenn es eine Solo-Q gäbe.
Eine ordentliche Solo-Q, das würde mich wieder zu dem Game bringen.
Ja, das Imperatorchen, das würde einen Meta forcen.
Was heißt forcen? Es gibt ja eins.
Und das ist ja nicht nur, weil die Leute sich das überlegt haben, so nach dem Motto, so soll jetzt das Meta aussehen.
Nein, das ist einfach zum aktuellen Patch-Stand das, was am optimalsten oder am universalsten funktioniert.
Ich meine, dass man einfach nur einen Held anklickt, würde Overwatch nicht gerecht werden.
Du müsstest dann schon so eine Mindestanzahl auswählen, die du spielen würdest.
Irgendwie so fünf oder so, sagen wir mal.
Also ich glaube, das würde schon einiges an Toxic-Verhalten rausnehmen.
Und eine ordentliche Solo-Q, eine reine Solo-Q.
Wo es dann auch nicht nach Stats geht.
Also nicht nach hellen Stats, sondern nach dem Motto, ich habe Lucio gespielt, habe viel geheilt, ich bin guter Lucio.
Weil in den Stats spiegelt sich das nicht wirklich wieder.
Oder zumindest nicht nur in den Stats.
Und reine Solo-Q, das wäre so mein Traum von ranked.
Eax, was geht dir an ranked am meisten auf den Keks neben der Toxic-Geschichte?
Die unausgeglichenen Matches.
Vor zwei Tagen habe ich einen Sechser-Stack gegen mich gehabt.
Deswegen sage ich, reine Solo-Q hätte ich wirklich gerne.
Können starten.
Reine Solo-Q wäre cool.
Da gibt es vielleicht Leute, die sagen, das fördert ja überhaupt kein Teamplay.
Also ich denke, die richtigen Teamplayer würden auch in Solo-Q versuchen zusammenzuspielen.
Da kannst du quasi gerade rausstechen, wie gut du im Team spielen kannst.
Was ist das eigentlich wieder für ein Match?
Weiß ich nicht, aber es soll tun, da kann man Junken.
Da kann man Lucio spielen.
Wobei es sieht nach einer Dive-Kombo aus. Was kann man denn heute nehmen? Tracer-Plep.
Frag mich, ob die Matches so hart sind wegen meinem Smurf hier.
Warum, was war?
Ich habe teilweise 180 Punkte pro Match bekommen, das ist auch ein Dreadbar-Song.
Ich habe richtig rein gesuchtet, wo das angefangen hat im Smurf.
Ich glaube, man muss keine Logik darin suchen.
Ich glaube, das stimmt eh nicht. Egal, was man sich für eine Logik darin interpretiert, stimmt eh nicht.
Er hat es nötig.
Oh, nee, nee, nee. Winston, Winston, Winston.
Ich bin drauf.
Unser Winston ist runtergefallen.
Er ist gelaufen, kannst raus.
Wir gehen gerade drauf, ich weiß nicht so genau warum.
Ich muss mich heilen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, ich habe einen runtergeworfen, aber das war es nicht wirklich.
Wir müssen gucken, dass keiner flenkt.
Was ist das für ein Spaß?
Was will der denn? Das war sein erster Problem.
Nein.
Ich versuche noch mal zu kontesten.
Das war nichts.
Ich bin nicht verrekt da vorne.
Der Winston am Spot.
Wo sind die denn alle? Achso, sind alle tot.
Ich dachte, da geht jetzt richtig rund hinter mir.
Warum verrecken wir denn alle, bevor es losgeht?
Ich habe Ulti. Wenn wir mal einen gescheiten Push zusammen hinkriegen würden, wäre es schon nice.
Boah, geschreckt.
Ich kann vielleicht noch mal kontest zugehen.
Ja, probier mal.
Wir sind nicht zum Pushen gekommen, weil immer wieder einer tot war zwischendurch.
Jetzt war immer der Genji.
Einmal habe ich auch viel zu lange darum gecrien und versucht zu kontesten, weil ich gedacht habe, halbe Team ist noch da und in Wirklichkeit waren alle tot.
Wir müssen mal gucken, dass wir hier so zu Dings reinkommen.
Genau, zum Soldier, wenn wir die wegkommen.
Ich hebe meinen Speedbus auf, bis auf den Punkt. Ach komm, scheiße.
Ich habe mich unentschieden.
Winston, Winston.
Jetzt schicken sie schon.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, was die vorhaben.
Der Lucio ist fast da.
Ich bin der Soldier, der ist noch weg.
Boah.
Jetzt noch mal zusammen, schön gucken.
Ich muss den McCree holen, der ist noch nicht da.
Moment Leute, rennt doch nicht rein alleine.
Das läuft ja klasse.
Ich futter mal kurz mein Baguette fertig.
Ich glaube, da muss ich nochmal kurz zu Salat. Bis gleich.
Bis gleich.
Ich habe noch nicht viel gespielt.
Das erste?
Was meinst du, das aktuelle?
Weil du es ohne Zahl geschrieben hast.
Das erste habe ich gespielt, aber nicht viel.
Also das Warcraft 3 Dota.
Dota 2 habe ich noch nie gespielt.
Das erste habe ich gespielt, aber nicht viel.
Das erste hat ich gespielt, aber nicht viel.
Ja, ich hol's mir nur wegen der Kampagne, also ich will immer davon aus, dass der Multiplayer wieder stuckt, aber Kampagne geht schon.
Oh, jetzt Defens.
Oh, ich glaub, wir haben einen, der ist rausgeflogen.
So, so, was kommt denn da noch, ja?
Star Wars?
Das neue Gott?
Das neue Gott, ja.
Anführungszeichen neu, okay.
The Crew 2 müsste irgendwann kommen.
Okay, bist du so in Richtung Autorennen?
Nee, eigentlich überhaupt nicht, aber so Games, die so, ich sag mal, arcade-lastig sind, da kann ich schon Zeit reinhauen.
Und der erste Crew-Teil war ja richtig gut von dich, bis auf die Cheater.
Hab ich nie gespielt, also ich sag mir was, ja, aber ich...
Okay, ich muss wieder in-game.
Ist der Typ jetzt eigentlich da, der gesagt hat, dass er Flex-Screen hat?
Weiß ich nicht, schaut so aus.
Ja.
Ich bin beide oben.
Da ist die Anna-Macht, ja.
Ja, mit Lucio hast du nicht so die Wahnsinns-Healing-Power.
You feel that?
Everyone, heal up.
Schreckt.
Svennen können wir auch noch holen.
Noch mehr schreckt.
So, Speed hinter dir, komm zurück.
Komm zurück!
Oh, hier ist ein Tracer.
Hier nachher.
Die ist weg.
Ich bin hinterm Kart, ich bin hinterm Kart.
Fuck.
Wo geht hier was ab?
Winston fliegt.
Ich komm nicht hoch.
Tracer bei mir auf den Punkt.
Ich bin oben.
Tracer geht Richtung Spawn.
Sven, neben dir.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Der Winston, der Winston.
Fuck.
Tor.
Zarya.
Fuck.
Ich rechtsklickt.
Ich bringe unseren Torb mit vor.
Ich hab Ulti.
Nee, nicht verrenken, nicht verrenken.
Fuck, ich hab's nicht.
Da können wir nicht rein, McCree.
Letzter Push.
Können wir die da vorne wegpushen?
Rechts sind welche drinnen, zwei Stück.
Fuck.
RIP.
Jetzt hauen sie aber alles raus.
Jetzt hauen sie aber echt alles raus.
Ich hab alles rausgehauen.
Wer ging nicht?
Gaming mit Schlips.
Schaust du regelmäßig
Overwatch Streams von Pros?
Ich gucke eigentlich hauptsächlich
Teimo.
Teimo, bester Overwatch Stream.
Wir hätten uns nicht alle
catchen lassen dürfen da drinnen.
Ich versuche uns
Orisa zu heilen.
Wo sind der Rest?
Nicht so weit rein.
Nicht so weit rein, Jungs.
Ich weiß nicht genau
von wo der Soldier kommt.
Fuck.
Von hinten.
Ich hab das nicht.
Was ist das denn?
Ich bin da.
Fuck.
Ich hab von Teimo
doch kein Kusschen bekommen.
Ich guck nur immer. Ich leecher sozusagen.
Mitte ist auch schwer.
Wir haben gar keinen Tank mehr.
Haben wir nicht?
Äh, naja gut. Das ist nur eine Dieve übrig geblieben.
Sag mal!
Bleib weg, ich muss gleich ulten, sobald die rankommen.
Ich kann nicht ulten, es ist keiner da.
Fuck.
Ja.
Ja, das war aber echt schon am letzten Drücker.
Kommt her Leute, lasst euch heilen!
Macht den Gengu kaputt!
Komm noch zwei Pushes!
Da konntest nix machen, Hanzo ist oben!
Und Leute, macht es doch nicht so durcheinander!
Ich bin noch an der Paylord!
Ich hab noch keiner, keine Ulti!
Okay, wir haben aber einen gekillt, das heißt wir haben noch mal einen ordentlichen Engage!
Der Zen ist fast tot!
Boah, der hat getrampst, ich bleib auf dem Paylord!
Was, der Boost ist real!
Boost ist real!
Ja, die Runde war chilliger!
Ja, das ging!
Bisschen leichtsinnig gevibe am ersten Punkt, mit irgendwie vier Mann in der Craft-Round!
Ja, die Game, have fun, Windows Neuinstallation!
Bist du auch jemand, der einfach Random Windows Neuinstallation macht, egal ob was braucht
oder nicht?
Wenn von Weiz geht, gibt ja so Leute, die überlegen sich so, ha, Sonntag Mittag, was
könnte ich jetzt machen, Windows Neuinstallation!
Liever, wer ich großer Fan von, liever Dive oben rechts, best with Winston drauf und in
your face!
Und mit Reinhard ist er halt sehr statisch da unten lang!
Boah, ich hab bestimmt nen Chunk gehört, das ist der neueste Meta irgendwie!
Hansu, Hansu!
Ja, auf gehts rein, busch, busch!
Oh nee, oder?
Wann haben die Doomfist?
Ja!
Komm Leute, go, macht was, push auf den Punkt oder irgendwas!
Schreckt!
Den Kopf!
Ha, ha, ha, ha, so nicht!
Ich bleib mal drauf, D!
Haaa, SHAKES!
ich habe speed
nur
Okay, oder?
Au!
Ja, komm, die D.Va, hier, zack, zack, weg damit!
Mh, der Doomfist von hinten, weggefistet!
Okay, die Va lauf
Moment, Genji fehlt noch
Mh, der Doomfist von hinten, weggefistet!
Mh, C9
Easy, direkt
C9
Also, der Rein hat echt ein bisschen aggressiv, oder?
Der ist nicht hingelaufen mit Speed oder so, sondern ist einfach mal rein gechargt
Ja, normalerweise, Kromstar, normalerweise hört man das nicht, das muss ich mal sagen
Das Leertaschen gesmeshe, weil ich dann meinen Herzanlaufer
Und jetzt hab ich auf dem Tisch das Mikrofon-Ständer
Ich guck mal, ob ich mir vielleicht so ein Mikro... Ich hab ja so ein Mikrofon-Ständer
Ich könnte es eigentlich mal mit damit ausprobieren
Müß ich doch gucken, wie ich da das Blue Yeti dran krieg
Ich geh mal kurz noch in den Klo
Kurz ab, Leute
Ich geh mal kurz in den Klo
Okay, wenn Ejax auch AFK ist, dann versuche ich mal meinen Mikrofonständer zu basteln.
Gucken, ob das passt.
Wo habe ich denn das Teil überhaupt?
Ja, das liegt echt in der letzten Ecke, Leute.
Aber in der letzten Ecke...
Bleibe am Start.
Kann man vergessen, weil das Blue Yeti irgendwie ein größeres Gewinde unten hat als mein Mikrofonständer.
Und eine Spinne für das Ding habe ich nicht.
Also, wird das mit Mikrofonständer nix.
Also, wenn ich jetzt mal den Mikrofonständer aufstehe, dann sieht man, dass das nicht so gut ist.
Gucken, ob ich noch irgendetwas habe, wo das dranpassen könnte, weil ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es geklappt wird.
Das ist wirklich ein bisschen nervig.
Hm.
Wo könnte man das denn anschließen?
Wo könnte ich das denn anschließen?
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Ja, was drunterstellen zum Entkoppeln ist eine gute Idee, das kann ich machen.
So, ich will ja irgendwann mal irgendeinen Schaumstoff, irgendeine Schaumstoffunterlage...
So, wieder am Start.
Hm.
Da habe ich bestimmt was, die Frage ist noch wo.
Oder im Kissen oder so.
Ich stelle den Kissen drunter.
Hier, Kissen.
Probieren wir mal aus, ob das jetzt weniger klappert.
Jetzt fällt es fast um mit Kissen drunter.
Perfekt.
So.
Baby.
Kannst du kaum achten, wenn du Bauch hast.
Jetzt fällt das Mikrofon.
Das ist auch nicht so Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Aber guckt mal, ob das Klappern jetzt theoretisch besser ist.
Eigentlich nicht, oder?
So.
Jetzt höre ich mal selbst in Stream rein, wie es jetzt ist.
Zufall kann ich meine Tastatur natürlich bewegen.
Weil das Kissen zu fett ist.
Okay, okay, so passt das.
Ein Stream reinhören.
Na ja.
Mehr kann ich jetzt gerade nicht machen.
Ich habe die Idee für dich.
Was denn?
Deinen Sprung auf die Maustaste.
Oh nee, damit komme ich nicht klar.
Ich habe es mal probiert am Anfang.
Wo so Luciometer angesagt war Mausrad.
Weiß nicht, ob du das mitkriegt hast, war am Anfang voll angesagt.
Alle Jump auf Mausrad.
Ich komme damit nicht da.
Ich brauche Space.
Wo hast du das?
Leertaste.
Jump muss Leertaste sein.
Ja, oldschool, ne?
Geht nicht anders.
Dann kannst du mal go machen.
Ja, mach ich.
Schlimm, ich bin seit 8 Stunden online.
Echt?
Ja, 10.30 habe ich angemacht.
Oh Mann.
Ohne Pause.
Also ausnahm mal aufs Klo.
Ja, das Cheesy Pro, das stimmt.
Ich habe einen Stream für Overwatch neu gestartet zwischendurch.
So, jetzt bitte noch mal easy game.
Und wie stand das für die ganzen Follows?
Das waren jetzt nur die zwei easy Games, die wir haben.
Jetzt geht es nur auf.
So easy waren die halt auch nicht, die waren halt ganz gut zu gewinnen.
Also ich bin jetzt aufs Klo, ich bin jetzt auf dem Klo.
Und ich bin auf dem Klo, ich bin auf dem Klo.
So easy waren die halt auch nicht, die waren halt ganz gut zu gewinnen.
Aber easy ist nice, was anderes.
Sebaru, ich dachte, das sieht immer so aus.
Pass mal auf, nachher sind wir mit dem Einranken fertig.
Du landest bei Platin, nicht bei Grandmaster, du warst das mit Duke.
Ich versuche hier einfach gar nichts mehr rein zu interpretieren in das Ranking.
Das kommt so, wie es kommt.
Weil egal, was du dir überlegst, es ist eh anders.
Und es funktioniert auch nicht so, wie du dir das vorstellst.
Mal gucken, wahrscheinlich werden wir am Ende beide Diamond oder so.
Wobei, das Game denkt ja noch, wir gehören auf Grandmaster.
Oder so Master Grandmaster.
Denkt das Game.
Sonst würde uns das nicht in Games stecken, wo hauptsächlich Grandmaster drin sind.
Stimmt Sebaru? Ja, das war früher das Rot-Weiße von Avira.
Aber das gibt es nicht mehr, das ist nicht Web 4.0 genug gewesen.
Anoma, danke für die ganzen Follows und schaut mal bei Erics vorbei, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich mache mal ein bisschen Werbung für dich.
Wie ist denn dein? Jetzt wo ich offline bin.
Du hast doch gestern gestrebt.
Ja, aber das war jetzt Ausnahme.
Ach so.
Der Kipp ist es, der echte Kipp.
Guck mal, komplett unrankt alles.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob das der echte Kipp ist.
Ist das der echte Kipp? Nee, der echte Kipp müsste mehr Genji haben.
Das ist nicht der echte Kipp, das ist der Fake Kipp.
Der müsste mehr Genji haben.
Du kennst den doch, oder? Ja.
Der hat ja null Genji, der Typ hier.
Das ist Support-Main.
Das ist nicht der echte Kipp.
Hello, hello, hello. Hello, das ist der Fake Kipp.
So, ihr könnt ja mal schreiben, wie es geklappt ist.
Was meinst du? Es ist komplett unrankt.
Ja, das heißt, es kann jetzt gestompt oder gestompt werden.
Eins von beiden.
A Tracer ist auf jeden Fall eine super Wahl dafür.
Also das Outplay-Potenzial am höchsten.
Wenn die Gegner sagen.
Da könnte ich ja mal was anderes spielen als Lucian zur Abwechslung.
Glaub ich weniger. Mal gucken, mal gucken wie die Gegner sind.
Der Chungler hat nicht mal viel. Ich bin Purple.
Ich weiß das deutsche Wort nicht. Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Es ist keiner mehr da, das ist das Problem.
Der andere ist immer noch im Laufen. Wollen wir jetzt reinpushen?
Ich hab Speed an.
Oh, du bist fast tot.
Jetzt liegt rechts eine Falle, Achtung.
Ok, ich bin bei dir.
Ok, gehen wir auf den Punkt.
Nope, gehen wir nicht auf den Punkt.
Also ich bin da auf dem Punkt, aber irgendwie ist da keiner.
Hallo, wir brauchen Hits, komm.
Hallo, wir sind ein Pro-Player.
Wer ist ein Pro-Player?
Kibbe.
Er spielt nur für dich.
Das ist nicht echt der Kibbe.
Ja.
Oh Mann.
Also das ist mal richtig von Arsch hier.
Wir müssen mal re-crew warnen sich.
Aber ich frag mich eh warum der ganze Spam durchkommt, wenn wir nicht jeder haben.
Ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich will er nicht rechts klicken.
Dafür waste ich nicht meine ULs.
Warum schießt da keiner drauf? Das war auf 5% oder so.
Jetzt machen sie ihre ULs, jetzt wohl ich tot bin.
Ok, go go.
Der Junkle ist mega behindert, ohne Witz.
Der Junkle ist rechts im Haus.
Oh.
Ich bin übrigens auf dem Payload, ich kann gerade nicht viel machen vorne.
Ich pushe einfach mal weiter.
Ich bin auf dem Payload, ich kann gerade nicht viel machen vorne.
Die werden aber richtig geregt gerade vorne.
Da hatte ich re-crew nicht.
Ich bin auf dem Payload, ich kann gerade nicht viel machen vorne.
Ihr seid nur noch zur 2 vorne.
Fahrer über dir.
Ich bin über euch.
Pass auf, rechter Ausgang, wo du raus willst, sind alle.
Ihr Leute pusht heute hin.
Nein, ich habe sie dir rausgeboot.
Habe ich sie dir aus deiner Puls prompt?
Prost. Aber ich habe sie durchgebrusht.
Kleines Urlöt hier, 20 Prozent.
Merci.
Fuck, down.
Steigst du auch auf Witmi um, ne?
Geht da noch was vorne?
Jaja, noch. Jetzt nicht mehr.
Okay Leute, kommt zurück.
Nicht reinholt, lasst mal, ich guck mal.
Au! Warum sind wir so weit zurück?
Hört euch doch, was das ist.
Also ich muss mir diese visuals
Was? Alter. Fuck. Richtig dumm rein gerannt. Hallo Voracius. Kriegen wir das doch mal
kontestet? Ne. Das geht nix mehr, ne.
Oh, da sind wir doch.
Wer war denn noch zweiter Healer letzte Runde? War das der Clu? Ja, gehe ich mal von aus.
Der hat hauptsächlich Zen, Ana, Lucio, Season 4, 30 Stunden, Ana. Aber ich will jetzt echt
keinen Reihard picken oder sowas. Fällt mir nicht. Im Zweifel kannst du Winston machen.
Je nachdem was die spielen, weiß ich nicht wie angesagt Mei noch ist auf dem ersten Punkt hier,
aber bei dem ganzen Dive-Scheiß kannst du es vergessen oder? Bringt das nix.
Genji ist da sehr optimistisch. Gehen wir davon aus, dass die mit
Final Mercy ankommen. Genji hat auch so ein Kram.
Ob nicht, dass sie mit einer Widow irgendwie reingejumpt kommen.
Die fliegt bestimmt außen rum. Ne, die ist noch im Tor.
Jetzt geht es aber los hier. Oh, was für ein Schlag ey.
Das ging schnell. Was spielst du da raus, Lucio, Ana, Zen?
Mit ein bisschen Übung, auch Roadhog, Winston, D.Va, eigentlich Support, Off-Tank.
Ist die hier oben oder was? Ich weiß nicht, ne, die sind im Tor.
Lucio ist richtig low, rechte Seite. Ich habe null durchgeblickt, wo die
Leute sind, ehrlich gesagt. Es waren zwei oben, dann welche rechts,
dann welche unten. Ich habe null durchgeblickt.
Wir müssen die mal contesten jetzt.
Oh Leute, hinter uns Genji.
Die pushen einfach durch. Die pushen durch.
Da ist keiner am Kart.
Geht ans Kart, Leute.
Vielleicht können wir es an der letzten Ecke noch mal ein bisschen halten.
Aber 430, echt massiv viel.
Wir brauchen nur einen Off-Tank, wir brauchen keine zwei Tanks.
Ich muss D.Va gegen Pharah wechseln.
Es ist besser als nur D.Va.
Ich muss mal scheren jetzt.
Nice, schöne Granate gefressen, äh Rakete.
Jetzt kommen sie mit dem Reinhardt. Ich habe gleich Ulti.
Die Pharah switcht aber auch nicht, egal wie auf die D.Va.
Die pushen jetzt wieder, sind zwei tot von uns.
Das war der Long-Range-Shot, du bist tot, ey.
Das hinterher, wir müssen kuken noch mal.
Mach doch die Pharah tot.
Ich stehe am Kart.
Was?
Der Reinhardt hat aber viel.
Wir müssen testen, jetzt räumt er auf.
Das wird knapp.
Noch eine Minute, noch eins bis zwei Pushes.
Jetzt müssen wir noch einen rauspicken.
Er kommt pushen.
Okay, noch zwanzig Sekunden.
Mit Glück kriege ich noch mal eine Ulti.
Ich habe gleich Ulti.
Ich habe einen Reinhardt.
Jetzt haben wir Spawn-Fanat.
ja current season
so mit der wache
kommen die placements die kriegt man jetzt noch fertig
die machen wir noch fertig
weil ich behalte mein altes eiken sonst finde ich mich selbst nicht mehr im grumpfenstach
so go go drei stück noch drei wins
auf geht's
also so voll weißt du so von den grundlegenden sachen her
so mit wann man zurückgeht wann man krupt und solche dinge was man halt
verlernt ist wie man welche maps spielt ja offensichtlich haben es manche nie
gelernt wie man halt manche maps spielt variiert halt auch das ist ja ich hab
das noch nie gesehen dass auf auf anubis am anfang dass alle oben links rum
gammeln aber das ist wahrscheinlich so eine orissa
geschichte let's go aber eins wo ich sagen neun stunden ist
zehrt doch ein wenig so an der belastbarkeit also ist schon anstrengend
erinnert mich daran wie ich mit dem stream so angefangen habe so nebenher
mit dem team zocken und so da hast du ja auch deine zwölf stunden am stück
gespielt
oder wie viel hast du
ich hab so so zwei rum angefangen bis um acht dann bis um zwölf
zehn sind zehn stunden nur zehn stunden
guck mal komplettes gm gegner team
ausdauer genau biernen
was soll das eigentlich heißen biernen slap slap da nur eins
slapst du die biernen oder was durch bitch bitch slap ja na ja in kontakt
und zuma also nicht nicht so oft
erkennt sich halt noch
zumindest hat er jetzt ein bad habe ich gesehen
hatten bad und hat wieder ein bisschen abgenommen
sieht es richtig frech aus der gute
man erkennt die guten fahrer schon dass sie hier boost machen aus dem start
ich weiß ich weiß nicht von wo die fahrer auf mich ballert aber sie ballern auf mich
ich bin auf dem point die fahrer kommt wieder rein an der seite
macht man dann fahren kreuz klein aber ich bin alt ich darf das
ich lasse hier laufen
genji genji richtig laut ultra lau
boost in reinheit vor fahrer fahrer kommt reingeflogen oder fliegt vorm
eingang oben rum
der winston ist mutig
jetzt verrecken wir alle gesplittert und ich kann mich nicht barrieren
wir brauchen auch keine barriere
jetzt haben wir natürlich schön beides support uns gleichzeitig gemacht
die fahrer fahrer kommt wieder rein
schön die support uns verkackt
der senna ob er was sagen könnte speedboost ist klar
wie haben wir das geschafft
fast tot ist fast tot die fahrer fast tot ja nicht mehr viel
ist
zockt noch wer auf der playstation du meinst overwatch
bierens lepter
so muss das sein die muss ins den offensiv kriegen sobald sie irgendwo um die ecke
dem in your face
Also ich habe Overwatch auf der PS4 nur mal beim Kaboom gespielt, ganz kurz, wowowowowowow
Bist du schon da?
Au fuck, ich bin in die Rakete gerannt, scheiße
Du bist der einzige, der noch lebt
Ach da!
Oh der Reinhardt, der Reinhardt ist richtig schlau
Okay wir müssen rein
Nein!
Na was? Der war doch gar nicht gestockt
Hat der das gesehen? Wo war denn die Pulsbop-Kram?
Oh und die Trailacer, die hat nicht mehr viel
Ulti, 44, äh 24
Let's go Winston, Schoffers down
Ich hab gerade echt Pech
Seit wann ich Overwatch spiele, seit der Beta, bis Season 3
Wenn ich spiele
Ich hab Ulti
Oh fuck, die Pharah lebt noch
Der Memelord ist fast, der Memelord, der Memelord ist fast tot
Oh fuck, der Memelord auch verlor
Oh das war nix
Das ist so geregt oder geregt werden, die Runde
Aber hauptsächlich wegen einem Hero-Pick
An der Boi, Ender Boi oder Aender Boi
Wie findest du den Content von Danny ehrlich, für die Zielgruppe nicht schlecht
Ich bin aber nicht die Zielgruppe
Vielleichtim
Wenigst macht er kein blödes Real Talk Dunes Ride
ich habe hier ein bisschen probleme mit der tracer
ein fahrer fliegt hier noch um
ich habe noch 20 prozent bis alt
zerrissen
ok komm jetzt das wird jetzt was ordentlich regroupen
ich werde hier gerade gehamtert
das ist aber ein bisschen spät
wo kommt der her wie er sich reingesneakt hat die fahrer in der mitte
nicht aufgebast
ich habe es ich habe es leider überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt dass die fahrer reingeflogen ist
aber wenn man sich das hätte denken können
die fahrer fahrer ist fast tot ich habe sie die tracer geht mir mega auf den sack
das gibt es doch nicht so krass direkt die leute und dann so was ich dachte wir haben den punkt locker
leute leute leute das ist immer so eine sache für sich
fahrer fliegt von hinten will mich abfangen tracer ist fast tot
da fällt nichts um faken klauen das ist noch nicht durch der max leider der falsche
falsche maxi play of the game
so verliert man die games ich weiß jetzt nicht was wir hätten großartig anders machen soll
das ist das bescheuertste was du machen kannst auf king of the hill
ich soll dich fragen wann du mal wieder streamst von general timbo gestern ja gestern schon
hallo ma doppel din manche namen sind schwer ja keine ahnung wir schauen vielleicht am
montag wenn wir mit den placements durch sind da vielleicht noch ich weiß es nicht
so zwei placements haben wir oder hast du mitgezählt weißt du wie viele placements noch sind 2
2 2 wirst du dir destiny 2 für den pc kaufen max ich glaube nicht ich glaube also nicht
weil destiny 2 schlecht wäre da kann ich nach der beta eh nicht viel zu sagen sondern weil
ich da wahrscheinlich von der zeit her gar nicht dazu kommen ja in top 500 ist klar top
500 top 543 easy anrennt das das ist auf erwacht schmelzmeck so muss das sein guckt
hier grandmaster top 500 anrennt und zwei anrennt so geht das von wo was von wo bis
wo gehen die rankpunkte von von also theoretisch von 0 bis 5000 ja aber nur sehr theoretisch
5000 gibt es ob es null gibt keine ahnung außer die typen weiß ich ob du das mitgekriegt
hast er damals die typen die halt in full step full stack die rankgruppe gemacht haben die
hab sehr einfach mal geschafft auf null aber 5000 hat die ersten paar seasons nevermore
aus korea nicht nevermore evermore wie ist der evermore nevermore keine ahnung evermore
ist der roadhog main der hatte 5000 der hat aber auch glaube ich zum größten teil full
stack gespielt und dann immer gewartet kurz vor dk wieder eine runde gespielt full stack
wenn der full stack spiele spiele hat nicht mit irgendwelchen nubs full stack sondern
mit den besten es gibt und ansonsten kenne ich keinen anderen 5000
ok sobald der winston rein gogo ich bin auf dem punkt top unten main
orissa hat mich gereckt in der mitte es gibt es doch nicht
ich dachte eigentlich wir sind jetzt locker durch aber so ist das es ist erst
aufer wenn es aufer ist ja kein healer ich bin da ich komme mal mit euch oben rechts
jetzt gleich lang ich glaube der daif funktioniert gerade nur so sehr befränkt
ich kriege auch keine ult charge damit
ja aber normalerweise sollt mein daif auch nicht mehr abhauen sondern hier durch die
orissa ist fast dauernd
links die fahrer
von hinten
ist
in
die
Das ist ja sicher ist sicher
Das müssen wir jetzt aber haben
Ah komm
Aber knapp
Die Sens auf dem Niveau können halt auch halbwegs aimen mit ihren Cousins
Die haben aber auch naja doch der McCree müsste die Fahrer killen
Da werden wir geregt aber hardcore geregt
70% Ulti
Ah ich hab Ulti
Ich kann mir das vollständig vorstellen mit Reinhardt und Beaver dass die Leute so schnell sterben
Wo sind denn die Fahrer? Fliegt die irgendwo hin? Warum?
Reinhardt Reinhardt Reinhardt! Was war das denn?
Der Lucio der muss jetzt sterben
Oh Leute Zen fightet doch nicht die Tracer alleine
Wir fighten die Tracer alleine
Ich will dafür nicht mein Ult wassen für so ein scheiß Engagement
So jetzt haben wir alle zusammen
Sind wir alle tot jetzt können wir alle zusammen gehen
Okay go go go
Oh nee jetzt jetzt war gewastet jetzt war gewastet jetzt jetzt war gewastet
Alles überzogen
Das war ich habe in dem Moment Q gedrückt wie der Reinhardt Gears Shattered hat
Das war absolut overkill
Macht ihr D.Va drunter?
Ja
Jetzt haben wir gerade alles mit Overkill weggenommen
Wir sind vielleicht noch durchgekommen
Was soll ich anderen Defense spielen? Wobei ich habe ich bleib mal Lucio
Jetzt komplett ohne Übung da die schnell unsere drei Tage wobei wir haben das ist
relativ langsam bekommt die wir haben da ist nichts außer dem Genji der groß falsch rumspringt
Machs gut wir sind Slapter
Ich finde den Namen geil wir sind Slapter
Nicht Scepter Slapter
Machs gut
Du bist ah du bist Genji
Moment das muss ich mal kurz in mich gehen
Wo ich mich da am besten hinstelle ich bleibe am Zen sonst ist der Zen im Arsch wenn dem keiner hilft
Ah ich dachte schon du musst in dich gehen weil ich Genji bin
Nee nee nee so war das nicht gemeint
Hätte zwar das Potenzial zum krassen Dis gehabt aber da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht
Ich habe ich muss in mich gehen wo ich mich hinstelle am besten
Nicht so weit vor Leute einfach in Ruhe hier
Wir müssen gucken dass Fahrer in der Mitte
Ich glaube die fliegt rechts rum
Ich glaube ich habe die Fahrer rechts rum fliegen gehört
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher
Heal Heal mehr Heal geht nicht
Fahrer ist rechte Seite ja
Da ist ein Roadhog drinne
Ich gucke da an
Und Tschüss
Ich wurde runtergekickt aber ich bin gleich wieder da
Ich bin auf dem Point
Nee da ging nichts
Die haben die Ult schneller als wir
Zurück Leute zurück
Hör mir einer
Was machen wir einstatt
Genji ist auf der rechten Seite
Scheiß Engagement
Was haben wir da so vorne rum gehampelt so weit
Ich kacke
Einmal kommen wir noch dran
Ich muss unseren McCree eskortieren
Down
Jetzt müssen wir aber die ultra krasse last point defense hinlegen
Sie versteckt sich hier hin
Voll im Kopf
Ich bin eingeultet
Wir müssen ran
Das könnte gehen
Ich habe in 10 Sekunden Ulti
Wir müssen ein bisschen safen
Die Mercy ist fast tot
Sonst überrennen die uns demnächst
Hier hat sie es nicht gegeben
Ich hätte noch ein bisschen rumstehen lassen können
Ich bin auf der rechten Seite
Wir sind ziemlich gesplittert
Ich versuche zu heilen
Die Fahrer
Genji ist noch am point
Wir sollten jetzt nicht alleine sterben
Das letzte push von ihnen
Ich habe jetzt eine schöne ult
Wir gehen aber glaube ich ein bisschen weit vor
Ich habe keinen Bock dass ich gepickt bin
Ich bin gleich wieder da
Das war es
Endlich mal ein gutes Play